hey guys it is the 24th of sep tember
today my name is Jess and he's not
married in gaming today the colors
debater for Rainbow six siege has now
launched across ps4 xbox one and pc UV
started inviting people to the beta this
morning but they've said invites are
going out throughout the day so don't
worry too much if you haven't received
one yet the beta is set to run until sep
tember 28 and to get an invite gamers
needed to pre-order the game or acquire
a key through other means Ubisoft have
said their main goal is to test the
online infrastructure and matchmaking
systems on a wider level and they did
during the alphas if you do get in
you'll be able to get your hands on
three maps three modes and hop into the
shoes of 14 operators a bunch of star
wars battlefront info drop today and
here's one you can get your hands on the
game EA has announced that the beta will
hit ps4 xbox one and pc on october eight
and will run until october 12 the beta
will let you play the 40 player Walker
assault mode a survival mission and the
new drop zone game type it's worth
remembering though that no progress or
achievements you make in the beta will
carry over to the full game while we
already knew that xbox one owners would
be the first to play battlefront Xbox
fansite I cxn posted up an EA access
image which appears to confirm that the
game will launch within the service on
November 12 that's five days before the
general public is set to get their hands
on the game on November 17 xbox boss
Phil Spencer who's had a hell of a lot
to say this week have come out to
explain why halo 5 has dropped split
screen he told GameSpot that the
majority of Xbox owners are playing
co-op across xbox live and not locally
adding I think the team made a trade-off
based on what they see happening in the
market today and what they wanted to do
with their game previously halo 5
executive producer josh homme said that
the decision to remove split-screen was
one of the most difficult ones we've
ever had to make as a studio Spencer may
be dedicated to the idea that you're
happy to play on xbox live but many
games but users express that they think
dropping
split screen is a big problem in our
on-site whole head to our story on games
but all that comments section to let me
know what you think about no split
screen in halo 5 you can add your game
spot where we've got stories on
Destiny's most recent update and the
games with gold you can get for free in
October that is everything I wanted to
tell you about today but do stop by same
time tomorrow my top five stories of the
whole week I will catch you then